[Music]
hello and welcome in this video we're
going to talk about a sinker weight
feature in JavaScript
first of all we'll go through a brief
history of async programming in
JavaScript we'll see how it evolves over
time we'll quickly take a look at the
callbacks promises generators and
finally a sink way so let's get started
okay so I already mentioned this but
this is a history of facing programming
with JavaScript so it all started back
with callbacks in the past and then we
were able to use promises which was a
major like shift from callbacks and then
we were also able to its generators now
I didn't use generators much I pretty
much like skipped over them so I went
straight from promises to a sync wait
but generators are in between those two
stages and finally like right now in the
present time we have access to this
honestly like amazing feature that is
called I think wait so what I want to do
next is I want to present to you a piece
of code and then I want to show you the
same piece of code in say callbacks
promises and async in the way after the
generators I honestly wouldn't want to
show that because I personally don't
have a lot of experience using
generators so I don't want to show you
something that maybe I badly written so
I'm going to skip over the generators so
let me show you that and here it is so
this is the callback exam now I really
didn't want to create like the most
complex callback example ever but trust
me that like this isn't the worst that
you can see it can get much much much
more uglier than thisis right now so
what we have here is a function that is
supposed to be an endpoint handler so
for example let's say you were building
some sort of a website and this handle
over here will receive requests from the
client for example the browser send
requests to the server and this response
object is what you can use to actually
write back something to the client for
example to the user browsing your web
sites so now what we have in this
example is we are talking with the
database and let's say we have a table
or say collection of users and we want
to find
a user that will be sent to us via this
request so we want to call this function
user dot find by ID and simply pass this
request user ID property but now this
function is a Singh one we don't know
how many milliseconds it is going to
actually run for so we need to do this
in async manner because otherwise we're
going to block the code and given the
JavaScript is single threaded language
that wouldn't really work so now we we
call this function and what we do then
is we actually pass it as a second
argument a totally different function
that will get called once these
operation finishes so we say here like
okay you go on database and try to find
me this particular user and when you do
that then and only then you call this
function that we passed over here and
pretty much like everything starting at
this line over here and ending over here
is the function that we pass to that
function over there now what this allows
us to do is say after this say in the
next line over here we can maybe do
something like console dot log and
whatever we do inside that console dot
log once this entire code gets executed
will be printed out before we see any of
this because this isn't done
instantaneously but anyway you can see
how it looks like and when you pass a
callback function so this function over
here is called a callback function
that's the reason why this pattern of
programming is called callbacks after
all and when you provide a callback
function you should always provide error
as a first argument
so then we can easily check if there is
an error by first doing that and only if
there is no error then we can move on
and do something else so in this example
if there were any errors we would simply
respond back the client pretty much
forwarding that error to the clients now
you see that we have this other argument
called user and what's going to happen
is this function over here user defined
by ID in case there are no errors and in
case it is able to find that particular
user it will send that user to this
callback function and it will be stored
in this variable called user so now we
have access to this user in this
callback function from here to here by
referencing this user variable so now
what we want to do is that user variable
is going to have a property called tasks
ID and pretty much in the same manner
let's say that we want to get access to
those tasks so we again like query the
database for those tasks given by that
ID so we do pretty much the same thing
and then again we supply the callback
function again with error as a first
argument and now tasks as a second
argument and then we again simply check
and if there were any errors we simply
want to respond back to the client with
those errors and if that wasn't the case
we want to do something with those tasks
instead so what we want to do is for
example imagine that that tasks had a
property called completed that is a
boolean type and we simply want to
change that to be true so now once we so
now once we actually modified that row
or document in our database we don't
want to save those tasks and saving the
task is again a sync operation because
it is not done isn't aeneas Li so we
again need to provide a callback
function to it and this time we don't
want to simply to receive any returned
value from it instead we just want to
make sure that that operation was
successful so then we simply check
whether the error was there and if so we
again respond to the client with such
error but otherwise we simply respond
back to the clients with the message of
tasks completed ok so hopefully like
this will make sense and you're able to
understand like the flow and you're also
able to understand like why is there a
need for these callback functions and
now let's take a look how all of these
like then the exact same code is handled
when it comes to the promises
and this is a promise example and one
thing you can spot straight away is like
how how much clearer and cleaner this
code actually is so this time what we're
doing is giving the user that find by ID
is again the same function and it is
again a sinc function we simply call it
and we pass whatever argument we
actually want but then instead of
supplying a callback function to this
line over here what we then do is we
take on the dot Dan function and then
there we actually supply you can think
of it like a callback function what will
happen once this operation is completed
so you can pretty much read it like this
like user defined by ID request user ID
like started this process and then once
it's actually completed only then do you
do whatever the code is over here so
when that's done we can then get a
handle on that he was a subject and then
we can do something now here we are
going to start another async function
called tasks dot find by ID so we pretty
much just returned that and then what
happens is we can just attach on like
another Dan to this piece over here and
then this part over here will only get
executed once this async operation
inside of here is actually completed and
now in the same manner we can do these
lines of codes over here and then tasks
that see if is yet another async
operation so we want to return that as
well and then we supply another function
that should be executed once this is
done and now we don't need any
parameters here so we just respond back
the client saying tasks completed now
you might be surprised how we didn't do
any error hand link so far so what's
going on is using promises you can
actually call dot catch at the end which
will catch all the errors for you and
then we simply want to respond back to
the client with such errors if that was
the case
you can see it's much clearer because
one error handling
doesn't need to happen all the time we
can just like have a specialist piece of
code that is going to handle errors no
matter where they actually happened and
- as you can see we don't have that
nesting pattern that gets really hard to
read that is called callback hell and
sometimes it is referred to like
Christmas tree shape because as you can
see it goes kind of like this and then
the opposite so it is definitely like a
much neater way to write async code in
JavaScript now let's take a look at the
same example using the I think weight
and here it is as you can see it's much
much much much more clearer than what
being able to see previously it almost
looks like a sink and the blocking code
but fortunately it isn't so what's going
on here is whenever you want to write a
a sink weight function you need to write
this key word async before the function
key words and once you do that you
actually have ability to use this a
weight keyword inside of that function
that is declared to be a async function
async/await is actually all promises
under the hood so like if you really
want to get a deep and detailed
understanding of async await feature
it's best if you learn promises first
but I'll do my best to at least explain
you what's going on over here so first
thing you can notice is we have this try
catch construct and that is how you're
able to handle errors in a sink weight
functions so this catch piece over here
is similar to the catch piece we have
seen over at the promises example we do
all of our error handling inside of here
and inside of our try block over here
what we do is next we call this user
defined by ID and again we pass the
parameters that we wanted but now we
actually write this a weight keyword in
front of it which
we tell dysfunction that this operation
over here is a sink operation and it's
not going to happen instantaneously so
this pretty much awaits dysfunction to
be resolved and then it stores the
result of it in the variable that we
assign on the left and now this next
line tasks equals away task was find by
ID will only execute after the user
equals of eight users and find by ID
gets resolved so you can almost like
read it like a sink blocking code so
next we await for the tasks and then we
supply this user dot tasks ID as an
argument and then we get those tasks and
then we can simple a task that
completely equals true like modify the
tasks and we can also save the tasks and
you can see because all these three
operations are a sink we need to put
this away the keyword in front and then
we can simply response out sent to the
client back message saying task
completed
now if error happened during any of
those three operations the execution
flow will jump straight this catch block
over here and it will respond back to
the client with such error so I hope
that now you can appreciate the
abilities that a sink weight feature
actually gives us as we do our daily
JavaScript a sinking so what I want to
do next is I don't want to stop here but
instead I want to go with you through a
bunch of async await examples in which I
could show you the sequential flow the
parallel flow I also want to show you
like all the loops and iterations that
you can do with async await I'm going to
show you some common cultures that you
might be unaware of at this moment and
all in all I just want to like go
through a bunch of examples so that you
feel confident in your ability to start
using this I think great feature today
ok so now let's do like a bunch of
examples so the
you can see all the ins and outs of
using async/await in your code so what
I've done is I've made like three
different folders over here first we
have a sequential then we have parallel
and then we have loops so those are
three topics that we want to go through
and in each of these topics we have like
for the sequential we have like a naive
approach then I'm going to demonstrate
like an issue that happens with it and
then I'll also propose the solution and
that's the same with the parallel and
then for the loops I'm just going to
like go over like the different types of
iterations that you can go with using a
sync away and explain like what you can
do and what you can't do so let's get
started with the sequential project
example and let's go in this naive
approach so we have two files that we
care about we have a main degeus and we
have a processes the J's
so if open main today's file you see
that we simply get a handle on those two
processes that we actually have inside
that processes file and the whole idea
about this small project is that we have
to process data async
and that we want to run them
sequentially so now like in that example
that I've shown you in the slides we
have this function main that gets called
over here and then we attach this async
keyword in front of this function
keyword and then we do all sort of
things inside of here so what we do is
we await for those two processes and
then what we want to do is we want to
store their values in these two
variables over here and then simply when
all of this is done we want to use the
console that lock to actually print out
to the terminal the value states we got
from those two processes and then this
console dot log is simply for like
formatting purposes and we also call
this console at time and console dot
time and functions which will tell us
how long
the function has been running for in
milliseconds and if there are any errors
we simply consulate error them again to
our terminal over here so now let's take
a look in this process the J's file and
see what's in there
so over here we just eat export two
functions that are also async ones and
in them we simply output that process
has started we again use time and time
ends to show to the terminal how long
this particular function has been
running for and likewise for this second
one and then we we kind of fake this
operation by simply waiting five
thousand milliseconds and for this
weight function I'm actually using a set
timeout but because that timeout is
expecting a callback
we're actually using this promise if a
function from the util package in no J's
which will actually turn this a timeout
into a promise based function that we
can use inside of our async code so
remember like the async is pretty much
like promises with a different interface
that we can interact with so we we can't
really use callback functions inside of
our async function all of that needs to
be promises that's the reason behind
this and I didn't tell this before but
I'm using node for this because it's
much easier for me to using all sort of
things like this that are already built
in but you can of course learn a single
weight and use it for like everything
that you do inside the JavaScript bit
backend be it front end your choice so
hopefully like this is this is making
sense like this is really simple
fake made-up example and when both those
processes are finished we simply return
some value for example process 0 1 is
going to return this processor 1 - value
string and process your 2 is going to
return this value instance so now let's
actually run this and see what you
so I'm going to use my terminal let me
just bring it up a bit and then I'm
going to navigate to death directory and
that subdirectory and then I'm going to
execute nodes and then main that yes as
entry point so as you can see processor
one started and it is taking some time
and then it says processor one ended and
it took roughly 5,000 milliseconds then
the process 0 to started and then the
process 0 to end it and that one took
3,000 milliseconds and then we see that
processor 1 returned back to us this
value and likewise for the second
process and then we can see that a total
running time for this entire example is
8,000 and so milliseconds and that makes
sense because when you take a look here
this one takes five thousand
milliseconds roughly and these three
thousand so that totally adds up so
that's all good and as you can see it
seems like it's working but you might
have noticed that I didn't use try-catch
blocks inside of these two functions and
that is kinda ok because if this or this
function returns an error it will simply
bubble up to this main function and then
we are able to catch it inside of here
so that's that's good but we will see
like what bad can happen in doing so in
our next example
and now I'll navigate to our second
example and show you the changes so if I
open this file main to Jess over here
and I close the other one so I don't get
confused
we have the same code in our main two
J's file over here and our process the
J's file is also the same but we did add
this throw new error line in this
processor one function so this is the
processor one is going to actually throw
an error once runs and we'll see how
it's how it affects everything over here
so let me quickly navigate that
directory
and let's see what happens when I run it
side line type note made of jazz and as
you can see a process 0 1 started and
then we get this error over here that
processor 1 failed so what happened is
this code started going sequentially it
came to this point over here and then
the proces ero 1 through an error and
then the execution flow jumped straight
from this line to the catch block over
here and that's the reason why nothing
of these executed afterwards so if you
have multiple processes that you want to
avoid sequentially this wouldn't really
work because as soon as one process were
to return an error the rest of them
wouldn't get executed now sometimes this
is really good because maybe if this
process failed you just want to like
exit everything and then you can use
this approach but if you really don't
care if this process you're 1 through
with an error or not and you simply want
to get like as much value as we can from
the other processes then this wouldn't
work for you so now let's take a look at
one approach that you can use to avoid
having this sort of issue so I'm going
to close both of these files and then
I'll open this 0 3 solution directory
and here we have the exact same main J's
file but this time the process the J's
file is different we again throw new
error inside of the process 0 1 and we
again don't throw any errors in the
process 0 to function but we did add
this try/catch block into both of them
and what's going to happen is as soon as
this processor 1 throws an error it is
not going to actually bubble up to this
part over here but instead it will
actually jump to this line in the same
function and simply do this and we'll
see how this would totally like save our
lives if we want to get this value
no matter what happens with the first
process so now let me actually start
this example I'm going to go back again
and go back into this new example and
then I'll execute node main and as you
can see process one started and process
one failed but we are still doing
something after that then we are
starting the process zero two and then
the process zero to actually
successfully ended after three thousand
milliseconds and then we see that we
have undefined value from the process
zero one since that is the process that
failed but we do have a return value
from the process zero two because that
one was successfully executed and we see
that the total running time for this
small example is three thousand
milliseconds because this first one
failed and then we didn't need to wait
those five thousand milliseconds to pass
by so with these three examples you
should feel more and more confident in
writing async obviously the more you
learn and the more you know about
promises it is going to benefit you a
lot so even if you're interested
async/await exclusively I would suggest
that you like take some time and go over
promises in your spare time but now
let's take a look at what happens when
we want to execute things using a sink
weight in parallel this time clear this
console I'll close this file and then
I'll navigate to our second directory
that is called parallel and again as I
already told you we have three different
there are subdirectories so let's open
the first one that is called naive and
let's take a look at it so this time the
idea is the same again we have two
processes and we want to run them but
this time we want to run them in
parallel and not sequentially that is
what this small comment says and how can
we do that
well first of all let me take a look at
the process with J's file just to show
you that it is the same as we had
previous
and it is also stripped of try-catch
blocks and we are throwing no errors
this time so in this main to JS file
what we do first of all is we have this
promise that all function ok so what
this promise total function does is it
returns single promise to us that
resolves when either all of the promises
in its argument gets resolved or if
there are no promises over here and this
promise at all also rejects with the
reason of the first promise that got
rejected in its argument
so all that might be a bit confusing but
the most important thing is this promise
at all will call all of these for us and
will return a single promise for us that
will get say completed when all of these
are completed and if any of these fails
then the promise that all will also fail
on that return promise with the reason
of that failure and what we can do here
is that the all the returned values from
this get stored into this data variable
that is actually an array and then if we
wanted to access the returned value from
the process 0 1 since it is the first
element in this array we can access that
by using the notation of 0
so we referencing the zeroth element of
this array and likewise for the second
process return value it is a second
element in this array and because it all
starts from 0 that is the first element
in that array and if we actually run
this example
and if I run it we'll see that both
process this time started straightaway
the process zero two is actually the
first one date ended with 3,000
milliseconds then the process year one
ended with nearly 5,000 milliseconds and
we can see that we have access to both
of those returned values and really
importantly this time we see that the
total running time of this example is
5,000 milliseconds and it is not eight
thousand milliseconds like it was
earlier because like we have those two
operations and the operations year one
is the longest one so the running time
is pretty much going to equal the
longest operation that we're running
because the other operations are going
to be completed by that time so this is
all great and it is working and now
let's take a look at one potential issue
that you might have with this approach
it's all close all of this and let's go
into the second folder okay so the issue
okay so this is the same like it was
before but if we come to this processes
we see that it looks awfully similar to
this example over here and in fact I
tried to keep them in the same manner so
the only change is this time we're
throwing new error in the process year 1
and let's see how that effects our
promise dot all function now if you
remember what it just said is that the
promise at all returns a single promise
and that single promise actually fails
with the reason of the first promise
that fails over here so let's see what
happens I'm going to start this
and there it is so we actually let me
bring this up so we started both of the
processes and then the processor one
failed and then the process zero to end
it but as you can see we don't hear
these never got executed because it
jumped straight to this block over here
and the total time running we also
didn't see that because again all of
these was avoided because of that error
so this is no good if you were
interested in at least say this value
over here no matter that the first one
failed so the solution is going to be
pretty similar to what we did in the
solution for our sequential problem that
was of the same nature pretty much so
let's quickly jump into it and see the
difference
okay so the main is the same and now
let's jump into the process of jazz file
and see what's changed and it is similar
to what we've been able to see before so
we'd only changed is that we added the
try-catch blocks into both of these
functions and again we're throwing a new
error inside of this process year one so
let's see how that affects things so I'm
going to navigate to the data directory
and then I'll type notes main and as you
can see so both of them both of them
start running but immediately the
process zero one fails and then we get a
notification process your two started
but this could be slightly misleading
because both of them got executed at the
same time so let me make one small
adjustment because now and the second
look at this could be a bit confusing
let me just simply before we train you
error let me actually just wait for
let's say 100 milliseconds or so just
want to show you that by reading this
you might think that this this is
executed sequential because you see
process one started process to process
one failed and only then process was
started but if I actually rerun this
example now we see that the both of the
processes actually started then the
process 0-1 failed and then the process
0 to end it and now we have access to
all of these over here because we
handled the errors more carefully this
time and we see that processor 1
returned well we don't know it failed
but we have access to this value that
approach 0 to 0-2 returned and it is
correct 1 and the total running time is
3,000 milliseconds because the first one
failed and second one it was running for
exactly that amount of time so now if
you ever need to run some operations in
parallel that are not depending one of
another you can use the promise at all
just be careful with the errors if any
of such processes can
actually throw an error and most of the
time they indeed can make sure that
Europe that you're handling those errors
inside of them and don't simply rely on
those errors bubbling up in your main
because as you can see it will totally
mess up the application flow so now
we've seen sequential execution we've
seen parallel execution now we are going
to take a look at loops and iterations
and see how can you do that using a sync
wait so I'll quickly close everything
and sorry I'll quickly close everything
and then I'll open the loops directory
and let's get started with a simple old
good for loop so I'm going to open the
main and this time the idea behind this
example is DIF which should be called
because we got a bit to use to the old
example that could be a bit boring by
now so this time we have our secrets
algorithm that we made and we want to
benchmark our algorithm and indeed make
sure that it is running in the time that
we think it is so what we want to do is
we want to run it multiple times and
figure out the average running time okay
and here we have number of tests or
number of runs that we want to to do and
just thinking about that let me actually
rename this number of runs because that
makes more sense
okay so we have number of runs that we
want to do we have our main function and
we have our for loop so as long as I is
less than number of France we want to do
it and keep incrementing that I variable
over here so we pretty much just want to
evade secret algorithm ten times in the
loop but we want to do some but based on
the description of this problem that we
are dealing with we are also interested
in time so I did pull in this
performance
now module for the node ecosystems and
I'm simply saving storing it in this new
variable and then what they simply do is
I saved a start time of each algorithm
run and after it is done I then save the
end time and then I pretty much like
calculate the difference meaning how
long this secret algorithm was running
for and then we simply increment this
variable that will hold all of the
running times of our algorithms and then
what we do is at the end we say total
time is exactly that number of retries
is number of runs that we have over here
and then we say the average running time
is we simply divide this total time by
the number of runs we actually did and
we simply format it to three decimal
places and in case of an error we simply
error it over here so it so it is really
easy the only confusing part could be
this performance now but that also
should make sense and now if we open
this process file things are slightly
different this time
we again export some functions this time
we simply export one function which is
our secret algorithm after all and then
we again use time and time end to
measure the running time by the way if
you're wondering why we didn't simply
use time and time and like we did in
previous examples to measure this total
time over here well it's because time
and time dot ends actually just outputs
the running time in our terminal but we
need to somehow store them in a variable
and be able to divide them by the number
of France so that's the reason why we
needed to use this as well
so now let's let me get back to this so
what we do is we simply await some time
but this time isn't static so instead
this is a small function I wrote this
will simply return a number between a
and B so here we're returning numbers
between 1 and 7 inclusive so both 1 and
7 could
happen and then we simply multiply that
number with 100 and that's how we get
our milliseconds that this secret
algorithm should wait for so it's really
simple and it is all I just made up for
this example but now let me run this and
let's see what happens so I'm going to
navigate to 0 3 loops and then 0 1 ok
and now if I execute that example we see
multiple secret algorithm runs over here
in fact there are ten of them we then
see that the total running time so all
of these values combined together is
5000 and nearly 300 milliseconds we
didn't see that we had an 10 rate rise
and 1 and once we divide this by 10 we
see that our secret algorithm is running
for roughly 500 milliseconds on average
so this is one example in which you can
use simple old good for loop and you can
see how the regular for loop plays
really nicely with oh wait we didn't do
any new stuff really
we simply awaited whatever we wanted
inside of our for loop and everything
was well so now let's take a look at the
for each which I really like and I made
a video about it in my year six series
and let's see what happens when we use
it instead of this for loop so I'll
close both of those files and let me
open the mental jazz now for this
example I wanted to create a slightly
different example so that I keep things
interesting and fresh so in this example
we're actually running a grid of power
plants and we want to somehow group them
together in a single array and be able
to quickly turn all of them on and off
so we have this power plant class over
here and let us first of all take a look
at that so if I open this power plant
file we see that this is a simple es6
class that is called power plants we
have a constructor and in that concert
we simply pass in
I did now i D could be anything so
that's just like the name that we'll
assign to that power plant in particular
and then we have two async functions to
this class we have turn on and turn off
and what we are doing we are simply
outputting that like turning on power
plant and then the name that we gave it
and then we're using time and time ends
to actually measure how long this
turning on operation took and then we're
using again the same weight weight and
we're getting some random number and
we're multiplying that by 200
milliseconds and then we simply do this
for like to get in your line so that
formatting is a bit prettier turn off
function is exactly the same we're just
like about putting different words to
the console okay so it's it's really
easy to understand and now inside the
main what we're doing is we're creating
a new array new empty array of power
plants then we are adding to that array
a new power plant five times and we are
simply giving them an ID of zero one
zero two three zero five and then what
we want to do is really quickly to be
able to turn all of them on and turn all
of them off so we use a forage helper
for our power plants array and then we
get access to every power plant in that
array and for each power plant in that
array we want while await in operation
of turning it on and turn it off so
let's see what happens so I'll navigate
to that folder and I'll type node main
and as you can see really quickly
something is really wrong and it's
actually not even running
so it says syntax error unexpected
indentify err power plant which is a bit
weird because we kind of defined it over
here but the problem is simply that you
can't use a weight keyword inside of
your forests so if you wanted to use for
each with a way you unfortunately can't
it but there are other ways that you can
and one solution to this problem is
using the for off so we're going to take
a look at that next so let me close this
file and let me open this next example
which is exactly the same so I don't
need to any explaining we again here the
same situation we are gandu the same
things we again have the same class over
here so the only difference is this time
we're not using the forage but we are
using the for off which is you simply
start with a for keyword and then you
write like the name that you want to
reference each and every element of
summary and then you simply type array
name so for every power plant that will
be in the power plants array we do
something and now like this needs to
match our array but this over here you
can call it simply X if you want this is
just a new variable for you that is
scoped for just this block of code and
then you can use it over here so I'm
going to undo that because this makes
more sense but just you're aware this is
this is the same that you head over here
so you could call this one X as well
okay so now in this for for of example
you can see everything is the same and
simple let's run it and see if this
works in this time so I'll go back and
I'll go in the for of example and I'll
start that off and as you can see it
seems to be working so we are turning on
power plants so we turned on power plant
0 1 0 2 0 3 0 4 0 5 and well that worked
and then we proceeded to turn all of
them off with this piece of code over
here and we turn them all off so this is
example how you can use the for off and
how you can't use the forage so that
should be main takeaway from these two
examples over here and now for the final
example let's take a look at a while
loop so I'm going to close both of these
files
and I'll never get here so this time
we're back again in our benchmarking
example so we are benchmarking our
algorithm again let me simply rename it
like I did in the previous ok in the
previous example so we have really
similar so the vi algorithm is the same
so I don't need to do any explanation
over here but the main is a bit
different I mean I made it so that we
really want to use while just so that I
can demonstrate while loop so what I did
is we have this retries variable that is
equal to 0 and we have total time which
is equal to 0 and then we simply repeat
this piece of code over here while the
number of retries her last and number of
runs so this over here will run ten
times and then again we stored the time
before running algorithm we store the
time after running the algorithm and
then we save the difference in this
variable over here now after each run of
this algorithm we want to increment this
retries otherwise this will be in
infinite while loop and then at the end
we simply output total time number of
retries and average running time this
time we can either divide it by number
of runs constant or we can divide it by
three tries because they will store the
same number in the end so let me do that
let me run this example ok no main and
let's see what happens some secret
algorithm starts running ten times and
this is our average running time so this
example simply wanted to demonstrate
that you can use while and it you can
simply use a weight keyword in the while
and everything works as you would expect
it to so and this is it I have run out
of examples fortunately so I don't have
anything else to show you
but let's simply do a quick recap so
we've seen that during the evolution of
async programming in JavaScript we had
different approaches with dealing the
async code we started with callbacks
we've seen that while they do get the
job done it isn't the prettiest code
ever and it can get really tedious to
follow the logic of that code that you
wrote so that that is the downside of
callback approach then we have seen that
the next best thing were promises and in
fact promises we are also going to use
promises in our async code you've seen
that promise at all function
you've seen that if you have some legacy
code or simply the mods that you're
using is he is implementing the callback
interface meaning it is expecting you to
passing a callback function you can't
really use it directly in your a sync
function but what you can do is turn
that function into a promise and then
you can use it with a weight keyword so
promise is really important there what
allowed the async to actually function
so be sure to like study on promises
then I briefly mentioned generators now
I don't really have much experience
using generators so I didn't want to
rush in and like create some examples
because I don't think it's really
necessary given that we have access to
async await
nowadays and then finally we've seen
about the sink awaits we've not only
seen like difference in code that it
produces in the slide but I've also like
walk you through all of these examples
and you will learn how you can do
sequential things using a sink awaits
like this you've seen the potential
issues you've seen the potential
solution in the strike heads
then we went toward parallel flow you've
seen how you can use promise at all
function over here and then we again
seen some issues and some solutions and
then last but not least we've seen how
you can use a sink await when you need
to iterate over through some the
and we have discussed four loops for
each for off and while so all of that
should help you out in the future and I
hope you learned something from this
video it is a really long one so
congratulation for sticking with me hit
through the end hopefully you learned
something it wasn't too complicated to
follow me and if you liked it please
leave me a like if you dislike it please
dislike it and if possible let me know
what I can do to improve in the future
thanks for watching see you in some of
my other videos